So the first one was, can I use the rife in bed while a child is in bed with me?
No, we get every almost every single person asked the question,
today, what about my spouse that's in bed with me?
Are they going to be, they're going to be a negative effect on the rife with the spouse
of the answer is obviously no, it's not.
If we're not running, if you're spouse, if you're running breast cancer,
frequencies and frequencies that were specific to you and your spouse doesn't have breast
cancer, then it's not going to positively affect them either.
But down there's not going to be any ill effects of the rife.
There really isn't any ill effects of the rife at all, unless your spouse or your
child in this case has Lyme disease.
So if a person has Lyme disease, then you just have to go slow.
The only ill effect is if you're running kill programs, Lyme kill programs,
if you're running Borrelia programs or some other Lyme colon infection programs,
you could kill too quickly and the person could have a detox reaction.
Those are not in almost anybody's rife programs for cancer patients.
They're obviously in their rife programs.
If you're a Lyme patient and if you're so, if you're a Lyme patient and your
child is laid in bed with you or your spouse is in bed with you, and they also have Lyme.
Yes, there could be some ill effects, but if you're a cancer patient and the cause of
your cancer is not Lyme, you don't have any Lyme frequencies in your program, in your overnight
program. So there is no ill effects.
If you have cancer and your child is sleeping in bed with you, even if it's a brand new
board, there is no ill effects for the child, runny cancer programs for your cancer and
for your case, while the child has been with you, absolutely not.
Two of my children, one has five children, one has six children, use, so I have 11
grandkids that use the rife on a very regular basis, and their parents did even when the
babies were very, very little. So I always say the rife is your go-to tool for the rest
of the family. So even though you have cancer, if your little two-year-old is coming down
with a horrible flu or a virus or a cold, you should be running cold and flu programs
on your baby and other people in the household as well, it should be your go-to. It's not
going to be a panacea for every disease, but it should be your first go-to for anything
you have coming up. So if you have a real bad cold, you should be running cold programs
on your children or if they have a stomach flu, you should be running flu programs, something
like that. So no, there is no ill effects of using the rife with a child in bed. Yes, you
could use the rife with a child in bed, even a brand-new newborn. You would have
tracked it mother, so there's no problems with that.